Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich bin Dr. Kokmas. Ich bin der Dienstabender auf dieser Station.
Ich würde mit Ihnen Aufnahmegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Gerne. Gerne, Herr Kokmas. Bitte schön.
Bevor unsere Gespräche führen, möchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Löwe.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname wieder?
Löwe, wieder Löwe. L-U-B-E.
Löwe. Okay. Herr Löwe. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Wie bitte? 5?
45 Jahre alt.
Okay. 55 Jahre alt. Und wann sind Sie geworden?
Ich bin am 15. Februar 1978 geboren.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,60 m groß und wiege 72 kg.
Okay, Herr Löwe. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Also, ich bin seit 2 Tagen tatsächlich mit Schmerzen in meiner linken Flanke.
Okay. Herr Löwe, diese Schmerzen, lustig oder?
Ja, die werden immer mehr.
Immer mehr.
Die haben langsam angefangen und jetzt tun die immer mehr weh.
Das stört mich sehr.
Haben Sie Veränderungen in Ihrer Urin bemerkt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Oder haben Sie Schmerzen bei Wasserlessen?
Hab ich auch nicht. Nein.
Okay.
Aber diese Flankenschmerzen, links.
Links, okay.
Diese Wicht, ja.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Also ja, die Strahlen in meiner Rücken und in meiner Leisten.
Rücken und Leisten?
In meiner linken Leisten.
Okay.
Wo würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala einordnen?
Schauen wir ein, aus leichter Schmerzen und sehen sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ja, also wenn ich die Schmerzen habe, dann würde ich schon sagen 8, 9.
Also richtig starke Schmerzen.
Okay.
Haben Sie aktuelle jetzt heftige Schmerzen?
Aktuell nicht, aber es kann sein, dass gleich wieder kommen.
Die kommen und gehen die Schmerzen.
Okay.
Wie beschreiben Sie Ihre Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel drückend oder ja, dumpf?
Also dumpf Schmerzen, die kommen und gehen.
Also wenn die kommen, dann kann ich nicht sitzen bleiben.
Das tut dann weh.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher diese Beschwerden?
Ob Sie Schmerzen schon mal gehabt haben?
Ja.
Ich habe sie zum ersten Mal jetzt, ja.
Schmerzen habe ich noch nie vorher gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Stürmern?
Nein.
Okay.
Hallo.
Lüwe.
Entschuldigung, Herr Lüwe.
Sind Sie ausreichend schlafen?
Schlafen Sie ausreichend?
Ja, aber momentan seit zwei Tagen nicht, weil ich immer wieder Schmerzen habe.
Okay.
Wegen Schmerzen.
Ja.
Ich mache immer wieder auch mit Schmerzen.
Die gehen nicht weg.
Haben Sie nachschweiß oder Stürzfrust?
Ich schwitze fast nicht, aber wenn ich Schmerzen habe, dann schwitze ich ordentlich.
Okay.
Weil es richtig weh tut.
Sind Sie übel?
Ob mir übel ist?
Ja.
Manchmal schon, ja.
Haben Sie erblicken?
Nein.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich habe Ibuprofen zu Hause.
Die nehme ich jeden Tag ein.
Ich habe bestimmt 20 Stück eingenommen.
Wie dosiert?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ibuprofen, keine Ahnung, welche Dosierung.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Lüwe.
Leiden Sie irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Zum Beispiel, Oblutthoktor oder Diabetes?
Ja, ich habe immer erhöhte Haarensäure.
Ich nehme dafür Medikamente ein.
Entschuldigung, akustisch nicht verstanden.
Ich leide an einer erhöhten Haarensäure.
Haarensäure, okay.
Ich habe immer wieder Giftanfälle.
Deswegen muss ich ein Medikament nehmen.
Was nehmen Sie ein?
Alu Purinol.
Wann haben Sie den letzten Anfall?
Letztes Jahr im Sommer.
Noch etwas?
Und das für meinen Magen, nämlich ein Pantoprazol.
Pantoprazol, 40 Min. oder 20 Min.
Und welche Dosierung Alu Purinol?
100.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Hausstoppallergien.
Wie äußert sich Ihre Hausstoppallergien?
Nichts.
Wie sind Sie vollständig?
Was meinen Sie?
Kinderkrankheiten.
Ich glaube schon, mein Hausarzt hat nichts gesagt.
Ich habe mich dann drei Mal entlassen.
sehr gut. Rauchen Sie? Ich bin nicht Raucher, nein. Trinken Sie Alkohol? Ja. Was trinken Sie
und wie viel? Ich trinke Bier. Jede Abend, oder? Ja, jeden Abend, fast jeden Abend.
Also wenn ich zu Hause bin, nicht auf der Arbeit. Okay. Wie viele Flasche? Ein, zwei, drei.
Zwei bis drei Flaschen. Okay. Die nächste Frage ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Rauchen? Was meinen Sie Erfahrung?
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Rouron ein? Früher her oder momentan? Ja, früher.
In meiner Jugend habe ich eingenommen. Aber ich kann abes geraucht. Aber jetzt mache ich das nicht mehr.
Okay. Und ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre soziale Leben und Ihre familiegeschichte stellen.
Ihre Eltern sind alle Altern? Ja, dort seitdem. Leiden Sie irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Meine Mutter hatte eine Schilddürfende in der Krankenhälfte. Mein Vater hatte eine Hütte Blutdruck.
Schilddürfe, Unterfektion oder? Keine Ahnung.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister? Nein. Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet? Nein. Haben Sie Kinder? Nein.
Okay. Leben Sie allein? Richtig. Okay. Was machen Sie bei sich?
Ich bin Busfrager. Haben Sie Stress bei Ihre Arbeit oder Privatlevel?
Übliche Stress. Okay. Normales.
Ja, für mich ist das normal. Es gibt keinen Tag ohne Stress.
Okay. Hallo. Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt. Haben Sie etwas fragen oder hinzufügen?
Muss ich heute hier bleiben oder kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Eigentlich, es ist so, zu sagen, ich muss erstmal eine Körperlücke untersuchen und dann
manche Bluttests und Bluttests machen, dann sprechen wir wieder darüber.
Was habe ich denn? Wissen Sie schon, was ich habe?
Oder haben Sie ein Verdacht? Was könnte das sein?
Ja, eigentlich, ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose, aber das ist nicht, ich bin nicht sicher.
Ich muss erstmal beweisen, dass es eine pülle Steine in ihren Nähern gibt.
Es könnte sein, ein Stein in ihren Nähern, aber es könnte sein auch vielleicht eine Darndenprobleme.
Okay. Ja, ich habe schon gesagt, ich muss ein paar Tests machen.
Okay. Aber ist das nichts Gefährliches?
Ja, ich denke auch nicht gefährliches.
Okay. Dann bin ich beruhigt. Dann warte ich jetzt hier.
Ja, danke hier.
Kann es ein Gichtanfall sein?
Sie haben schon darüber Erfahrungen. Ich denke, dass nicht gleich wie ein Gichtanfall,
aber es könnte sein auch, ich muss kontrollieren.
Wäre das ein Gichtanfall in der Näher?
Natürlich nicht, ein Gicht in ihrer besonders in Gellengs Entschuldigung.
Also Sie glauben ja nicht, dass es eine Gicht sein könnte.
Ja, ich denke auch nicht.
Okay. Gut. Ja, dann warte ich jetzt, dass Sie mich untersuchen.
Okay. Nehmen Sie eine Plastik im Wartensimmer. Ich komme gleich.
Alles klar.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen an Ihre Fragen?
Ich habe eine.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Gleich.
Machen Sie regelmäßig Sport? Treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Aber jetzt in der Kälte macht es kein Sport. Es ist mir zu kalt.
Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen zu fragen.
Haben Sie Fieber? Hatten Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe keine Fieber gehabt.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzattacken genaubere Schreiben?
Ja, der Kollege hat schon gefragt.
Also wenn ich die Schmerzen habe, dann habe ich so ungefähr auf einer Skala von 8 bis 9.
Aber die Schmerzen kommen und wählen.
Das sind dumpfe, krampfartige drückende Schmerzen.
Ich weiß, aber wie viele Minuten dauert diese eine Attacke an?
Eine Minute, 1 bis 2 Minuten ungefähr.
Wenn die Schmerzen gehen, dieses Durselbund seid keine Schmerzen.
Doch, da ist immer so ein Druckgefühl.
Als wenn da irgendwas wäre, was dann nicht hingehört.
Dann habe ich immer so 20 Minuten, 15 Minuten Ruhe, aber das wird jetzt immer mehr.
Also der Abstand wird kürzer.
Mittlerweile sind das schon alle 10 Minuten.
Deswegen bin ich heute hier im Krankenhaus.
Sind die Schmerzen abhängig davon, ob sie sitzen stehen oder liegen?
Nein, ich kann mich gar nicht bei denen verstecken.
Oder ist es eine
neue Art und Weise, die sich anfangen?
Ja, ich versuche es.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie kurz erst seitdem?
Gerne Herr Korkmaz, schießen Sie los.
Thomas Love ist ein 50-jähriger Patient.
Er kann heute seit 3 Tagen angefallen.
2-3 Tage bestehen Schmerzen im Flanken.
Schmerzen sind Dumms und Kommand-Gehren.
Die Schmerzen haben langsam begonnen und liegen auf einer Schmeisterkala bei 8-9.
Die Schmerzattacke dauert 1-2 Minuten.
Es ist die erste Episode.
Herr Love hat vielmals Ibuprofen angenommen.
Er ist unaufwählig bis in Sonne.
Er hat eine Schmerz- und Insomnia.
Er hat eine Schmerz- und Insomnia-Gift.
Er nimmt alle 300-1 und täglich Pantoprosol 20 mg abends.
Er hat Holstuppalergie.
Er ist vollständig geheim.
Er ist nicht rocher.
Er trinkt 3-4 bis abends.
Früher hat er Cannabis probiert.
Aber momentan nutze ich nicht.
Momentan nimmt er nicht ein.
Er ist erledigt und allein ist erledigt.
Er ist Busfahrer.
Er ist Busfahrer am besten.
Er hat Arterieulich.
Er hat Schilddrüse.
Er weiß nicht, was es ist.
Er hat Nephrolitiasis.
Was geben Sie gegen die Schmerzen?
Ich habe es erst mal mit Parastamol, aber wenn es sehr stark Schmerzenopiat könnte,
kann man es nicht mehr nutzen.
Man kann einen 1-4 Gramm Zahn geben, einen Buskupal geben,
gegen die kampartige Schmerzen.
Man kann auch eine Opioid geben.
Was geben Sie?
Was empfehlen wir Ihnen?
Wir sagen Ihnen, bewegen, bewegen, bewegen, springen, treppen,
hoch und runter, hoch und runter, laufen, laufen, springen.
Was empfehlen wir Ihnen?
Wir hoffen, dass der Stein von alleine abgeht.
Wir hoffen, dass er abgeht.
Würden Sie ihn nach Hause lassen?
Die Instaustelle Stau ist sehr wichtig.
Wenn er einen Stau dritten Grad hat,
dann lassen wir ihn nicht nach Hause.
Wir hoffen, dass der Stein von alleine abgeht.
Manchmal geht er nicht von alleine ab.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Würden Sie diese Situation eine Antibiotika empfehlen?
Ich glaube, ich würde das nicht machen.
Man kann es sicherlich machen, aber man muss das nicht machen.
Ein Kollege hat geschrieben, dass Intervenous Metamizol empfehlen wird.
Ich habe falsche Fragen.
Ich habe Metamizol, aber ich denke Metronidazus.
Wenn er als Hochgrad ist, und der Verdacht einer Pyrodene Fitness besteht,
dann muss man die Ölkommen machen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wir müssen die Patientin immer die Situation aufnehmen.
Wenn die Patientin immer weiter runtergewandert ist,
dann können sie den Patienten nach Hause lassen.
Wenn er den Stein auffangen kann,
dann kann man den Stein wegschicken.